[Music]
earlier today the president
announced a peace deal between bahrain
and
israel which is another massive huge
step towards
middle east peace so will the mob the
media give this
major accomplishment the credit it
deserves well they didn't mention the
first
piece deal with the uae i doubt it
they'll do it here
yesterday by the way new documents
released by the doj
showing that multiple members of
mueller's team actually
wiped their phones clean before turning
them over
to the inspector general and tonight
republicans are rightly demanding
answers
and suggesting this could amount to
anticipatory obstruction of justice
where's the outrage from the mob than
the media imagine if donald trump did it
joining us now white house press
secretary kelly mcinerney
okay well we had a lot of people get
prosecuted by
the mueller mob uh for process
crimes including obstruction and not
handing over emails and lying to
congress didn't we kaylee
yes we did and now we learn what
mueller's team was doing
several dozens think about that several
dozens of devices returned
damaged wiped clean some of them
intentionally so one of those devices
was
andrew weissman's two two of the devices
were white
two or weissmans who was rebuked 9-2-0
by the supreme court for prosecutorial
overreach misconduct
i'm lisa page too among these offenders
moeller
is saying we'll prosecute you for
process while we several dozens of us
are engaging in the same kind of
obstruction that is uncalled for
i it just shows the depth at which this
has gotten out of control because we
also
know that they were worn numerous times
uh even before the first fisa warrant
was issued
we know that they were warned by
kathleen kavlak at the state department
bruce ohr
christopher steele has an agenda hillary
paid for it and it's not verified they
signed it anyway
when they finally got to the sub source
in other words the source behind
steele's
dirty russian dossier that hillary paid
for well then they found out in january
of 2017
the sub source said no this was all bar
talk none of this is true
so it was never now we know it's
debunked so it was never verifiable
which means we never should have had a
a mueller investigation period but i
don't hear
from your friends that are in that press
room with you regularly
uh hammering you with questions about uh
these issues why
they don't care how many times have i
been asked questions
about very legitimate things like
michael flynn
the injustice done to him the obama
administration that oval office meeting
literally during my tenure we find out
that susan rice on the way out the door
writes this email inscribing a meeting
from
days prior weeks prior actually and says
obama did everything by the book
this was a very curious email not asked
about that because they simply don't
care and there are two tiers of justice
in this country
one for mueller's team and hillary
clinton and another for michael flynn
and the trump administration
well i mean mike look at you four years
of general flynn's life now put on hold
the president discussed this yesterday
president lays it out has do you get any
questions about the abuse of power and
corruption
of comey page struck mccabe and company
do you ever get any questions about them
zero literally zero from the reporters
sitting there in the chairs in the
briefing room
none and i even inquired to them how
many of you have reached out to obama's
office his representative
to ask some questions not a single hand
went up because they simply don't care
every single day i watch the media and
for example i i watched the president
the president acted on 10 days after the
first
identified case of coronavirus that was
january 21st
his travel ban went into effect on
january 31st joe biden on february 1st
actually said it was hysterical
xenophobia and fear-mongering
he said it all throughout the month of
january
the month of february and deep into
march
now he's saying oh no we we we supported
the travel ban at the time i'm like
huh yeah it's amazing they didn't
support the china travel ban they didn't
support the european travel ban
as you noted they call it fear mongering
they call it hysteria
and his advisor by the way saying this
wouldn't turn into a serious pandemic
and noting that his same advisor ron
claim
is the one that said we barely survived
h1n1 it was mere fortuity
that swine flu was not one of the mass
casualty events of our time
all right kaylee mcinerney i don't think
you get paid enough
i couldn't i could not do your job it's
job impossible
i'd have a very hard time keeping my
temper and checking them you do great
sean